SOME OF THAT INTENSITY OF
POWERS.
ONE OF MY TEACHERS IS WITH ME
NOW.
JANICE DEAN IS LIVE FROM THE
WEATHER CENTER.
JANICE.
>> WE'VE COVERED A LOT OF STORMS
TOGETHER AND THIS ONE IS GOING
TO BE FOR THE RECORD BOOKS.
THIS IS GOING TO DEVASTATE
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
CATEGORIES 4 AND 5 AND WE'RE ON
THE CUSP OF A FIVE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER ANY MORE.
THE DAMAGE WILL BE THE STORM
SURGE AND SOME OF THESE
VULNERABLE COASTLINES UPWARDS OF
18 FEET AND IT WILL COME DURING
HIGH TIDE.
IT WILL ADD AN ADDITIONAL 1 TO 2
FEET AND THE WAVES ON TOP OF
THAT.
PRAYERS ARE NEEDED IN SOUTHWEST
FLORIDA BECAUSE WE ARE --
LANDFALL IS IMMINENT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE HOURS AND THE HIGH WALL
IS NOW MAKING LANDFALL ACROSS
PORTIONS OF SOUTHWEST FLORIDA.
WE'LL FEEL THE HURRICANE-FORCE
WINDS GETTING GUSTS IN VENICE OF
OVER 60 MILES PER HOUR.
IT WILL BE A LONG DURATION
EVENT.
YOU MENTIONED THE SLOWING DOWN.
THAT WILL BE DANGEROUS BECAUSE
YOU WILL HAVE ALL OF THIS WATER.
THIS IS LIKE A BULLDOZER OF
WATER NOW FROM A VERY STRONG
HURRICANE THAT IS THREE TIMES
THE SIZE OF CHARLEY.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
HURRICANES THAT HAVE HIT THIS
AREA CHARLIE CAME ASHORE IN
2004.
IT WAS A CATEGORY 4.
THIS IS THREE TIMES THE SIZE OF
CHARLEY.
FOLKS THAT LIVE IN FORT MYERS
AND PUNTA GORDA REMEMBER
CHARLIE.
THIS ONE WILL BE WORSE THAN
THAT.
WE'VE COVERED A LOT OF
HURRICANES TOGETHER.
THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE WORST
THAT I HAVE EVER COVERED IN MY
CAREER.
WE'RE EXPECTING A LANDFALL
PROBABLY AROUND 3:00 OR
4:00 P.M.ENTER SLOWS DOWN, 24
HOURS ACROSS THE STATE OF
FLORIDA CRAWLING.
ORLANDO UNDER HURRICANE WARNING.
YOU MENTIONED THE TORNADO
THREAT.
DOZENS OF TORNADOES OUT OF LAND
FALLING HURRICANES AND WE'VE
SEEN TORNADO WARNINGS NOT ONLY
TODAY BUT YESTERDAY AND IT WILL
BE ON GOING.
THE PEAK STORM SURGE.
WHAT KILLS MOST PEOPLE IN THE
PATH OF A HURRICANE.
THIS WARNING IS 12 TO 18 FEET
VULNERABLE COASTLINE HERE.
THAT WILL OVERTOP HOMES.
THAT WILL MOVE WELL INLAND.
AND THAT'S THE BIGGEST CONCERN.
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE RIVERS
THAT ARE GOING TO CREST HERE AT
HISTORIC LEVELS OVER THE NEXT 12
TO 24 HOURS.
13-FOOT STORM SURGE HERE AND
AGAIN THAT'S FALLING ON HIGH
TIDE IT WILL BE FURTHER THAN
THAT.
IT WILL BE UPWARDS OF IN SOME
CASES MAYBE CLOSE TO 20-FOOT
STORM SURGE BECAUSE OF THE HIGH
TIDE.
THE TROPICAL RELATED DEATH SURGE
IS THE HIGHEST AND THIS IS WHAT
IS GOING TO INUNDATE FORT MYERS
UP TO SARASOTA, FLORIDA IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF HOURS.
>> Harris: QUICKLY A COUPLE OF
REASKS ON YOU.
A STORM SURGE WARNING IN EFFECT
NOW.
I MADE A POINT TO TELL THE
AUDIENCE THAT WHILE TAMPA IS NO
LONGER ON THE SHORT LIST OF
DIRECT HIT CITIES.
IN THE BEGINNING IT WAS AND NOW
IT HAS SHIFTED.
IT IS SECOND ON THE LIST FOR --
THIS IS NOT ALPHABETICAL.
SECOND ON THE LIST FOR STORM
SURGE DAMAGE.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE DISTANCE,
IF YOU WILL, FROM WHERE THE
STORM IS PROJECTED TO HIT
DIRECTLY AND YOU SAY THAT THOSE
HURRICANE WINDS ARE ALREADY
MOVING ON SHORE RIGHT NOW.
THEY ARE GETTING A FLAVOR OF HOW
BITTER THIS WILL BE.
HOW FAR AWAY IS THAT FROM CITIES
LIKE TAMPA AND ORLANDO?
WE MENTIONED ORLANDO FOR
POSSIBLE TWISTERS.
>> THE WHOLE STATE OF FLORIDA IS
IN A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
WE THINK THE CORE OF THE
STRONGEST WINDS WILL COME ASHORE
AROUND THE FORT MYERS AREA.
IT'S JUST SOUTH OF TAMPA BAY.
WE THOUGHT TAMPA WOULD TAKE THE
BRUNT OF THE STORM.
THEY'LL STILL SEE STORM SURGE
TOTALS OF SIX FEET.
THE WORST OF THE DAMAGE WILL BE
SOUTH OF TAMPA.
FORT MYERS IS ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE COASTLINES.
NAPLES, SARASOTA.
SOMETHING THEY'VE NEVER SEEN IN
THEIR LIFETIME IN THIS REGION.
SO RAIN TOTALS, YES, CERTAINLY
WE COULD SEE OVER A FOOT OF
RAINFALL.
IT IS THE STORM SURGE, 12 TO 18
FEET AND AGAIN COMING AT HIGH
TIDE AND THE WAVES ON TOP OF
THAT, HARRIS.
IF YOU KNOW THE REGION.
IT IS LOW-LYING BEACH AREAS AND
THE WATER WILL COME ON TOP OF
HOMES.
THAT'S WHY YOU CAN HIDE FROM THE
WINDS, YOU HAVE TO RUN FROM THE
WATER.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED, THE TIME
HAS RUN OUT AND WHY I'M SO
SCARED AND THE PRAYERS NEED TO
BE SAID FOR THIS PORTION OF
SOUTHWEST FLORIDA.
>> Harris: A COUPLE OF THINGS,
CORRECTION FROM ME.
IT IS FLAGLER, I STRUGGLED WITH
THAT.
I APOLOGIZE.
270,000 PEOPLE IN FLORIDA NOW
WITHOUT ELECTRICAL POWER.
EVEN AS THE WINDS, THE OUTER
BANDS ARE MOVING IN FROM
HURRICANE IAN, IT IS COMING IN
WITH A FURY.
LAST QUICK QUESTION.
YOU SAID NOT MUCH DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A CAT FOUR AND CAT FIVE.
DOES IT MATTER IN TERMS OF HOW
LONG IT TAKES THE INTENSITY OF
THOSE WINDS TO DIE DOWN?
>> WE ARE GOING TO SEE THE STORM
WEAKEN IN THE NEXT 12 TO 24
HOURS BUT STILL BE INTACT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A HURRICANE
WARNING IN ORLANDO.
WE ARE STILL EXPECTING
HURRICANE-FORCE WINDS WELL
INLAND AND TO THE ATLANTIC SIDE
OF FLORIDA UP TOWARD THE GEORGIA
AREA.
WE STILL HAVE HURRICANE WATCHES
AND ADVISORIES IN THOSE AREAS.
WE EXPECT THE STORM TO HOLD
TOGETHER IN THE NEXT 12 TO 24
HOURS.
THE CATASTROPHIC DAMAGE WE'RE
EXPECTING IS GOING TO BE ALONG
THE COAST.
>> Harris: WATER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Harris: WE CAN HIDE FROM THE
WIND BUT YOU HAVE TO RUN FROM
THE WATER.
WE'LL CHECK BACK.
WE KEEP GETTING UPDATES